The sun’s gone bad! People and
animals are melting everywhere!
The world is coming to an end and there’s
nothing I can do about it! Will I be able to
find food? Will I be able to defeat or avoid
the horrific flesh monsters all around me,
or the desperate and hungry survivors left in this
terrible new world? Keep watching and find out.
Can I survive 100 days in
SCP-001 - When Day Breaks!?
Hey folks, it’s ya boy, Kyle.
You probably know me more for
gaming videos than post-apocalyptic
vlogs, but hey, I’m a versatile guy,
and I think I might go insane from the fear if I
don’t talk to somebody about all this craziness.
If you’re alive and seeing this right now,
well, congratulations, you’re probably doing
a lot better than most people here, if you can
call them “People” now. But if you’re seeing
this a few years in the future, like, I
don’t know, you woke up from a ten-year
coma like Rick from The Walking Dead and you’re
wondering what the hell happened to Planet Earth…
This video is probably gonna answer a lot of your
questions. First thing’s first, whatever you do,
you’ve gotta stay away from the sun. It touches
you even for a second, you’re dead, or worse.
Welcome to Day One of the End of the World.
For all of you who are still in a solid state
of matter, you’re probably wondering how I’m still
alive, too. Chances are, it’s for the exact same
reason you are: Sheer, dumb luck. I was down
here in my gaming basement when day broke, just
level grinding when my TV got taken over by those
SCP Foundation people, telling us that the sun’s
gone evil for whatever reason and now we’ve all
gotta stay inside. Hell, if I was up there making
myself a sandwich or grabbing another can of
Mountain Dew, I’d be a freaking puddle right now.
It’s funny, my mom always told me
spending all day indoors was bad for me.
I’ll have to mention that to her, if she’s alive…
Point is, the world has gone to hell in a
handbasket and I’ve now got only one objective:
Survive! I’m gonna see if I can survive the
horrifying, post-apocalyptic world of When
Day Breaks! For this first day, I’m just gonna
hunker down. I kinda hope this is just a dream…
Day 2. Alright, I’m up and at ‘em, baby. Sadly,
I can now report that this isn’t a dream.
This really is our horrible new reality. It’s
the sun’s world, and we’re just living in it!
I’ve been spending the last several hours just
waiting for nightfall outside. Against all odds,
the internet and the power grid haven’t gone
down yet - Guess whatever’s wrong with the
sun only affects people and animals, not
objects. Thank heaven for small mercies,
right? People on Twitter have been
live-posting their situations out there,
sharing advice on how we might all be able to stay
out of the sun and survive this whole crazy thing.
And hey, unless they’re dead or full of hot
air, maybe those “SCP Foundation” people
know something about what’s going on here.
If we really can get to their buildings,
maybe we can figure out how to reverse all
this mess. Maybe. For now, I’m just gonna
focus on staying alive. Hopefully night
hits soon, I really need the bathroom…
Oh boy, it’s Day Three and new issues are starting
to pop up. I’ve been heading upstairs to go to the
bathroom, but while I don’t want to be crude, I’m
running low on toilet paper and it’s starting to
become a problem. I ran out of my last roll a
few days ago, and now, I’m starting to go to my
bookshelves. I had a few newspapers left that
I tore up and used for toilet paper first.
They weren’t exactly comfortable,
but hey, you need to make do.
But without toilet paper and without
newspapers, I need to figure out what my
favorite and least favorite books are.
I’m starting with the prefaces of all the
books - seeing as I don’t generally need to
re-read them. They’re expendable, you know?
A lot of these books I haven’t read since I
was fifteen, so maybe those’ll be the ones.
I can’t make my mind up on whether
I’m gonna use the Harry Potter books
or the Percy Jackson and the Olympian books first.
Uhhh, let me know what you think in the
comments, I guess. I need to go to the bathroom.
Day Four, and now, I’m trying to figure out
how to pass the time. As you already know,
I’m an avowed, life-long gamer. So, while
the electricity and the internet still work,
I’m gonna keep gaming to pass the time and keep
my all-too-precious sanity. I still have no
intention of going out there, even at night,
but it’s left me feeling kind of stir-crazy.
I want to walk around the city again, I want to
go for a drive and feel the breeze in my hair.
But seeing as I can’t do that without
experiencing a truly horrifying transformation,
I’ve been spending a lot of time on GTA V
online. Guess we’ll never get GTA 6 now,
what a bummer. Still, these last few days it’s
felt more like Los Santos has been my home than
where I actually live. There were even a few other
people on the server. I don’t know about you, but
I take some comfort in that.
Hey folks,
I’m back, thankfully. Welcome to Day Five.
We’ve still got electricity, thankfully, hence why
you can still see this. I haven’t heard anything
from my family. I don’t wanna assume the worst,
but… It’s probably just best not to think about
it. I’ve been heading up and downstairs to grab
more food at night. You’re probably wondering,
“But Kyle, why don’t you bring it all downstairs
to save going up altogether?” To which I’d say,
I don’t have a fridge downstairs, smart-ass.
But I’m starting to realize food is gonna
be a real issue here. It’s kinda stupid,
now I think about it - In all the zombie movies
and TV shows I used to watch, it was all bullets
and baseball bats. Killing your way through
all those undead freaks and worrying about the
rest later. Guess they don’t want
you to think about how you’re only
ever a couple of weeks away from starvation, kinda
ruins the badass post-apocalypse power fantasy.
I only have a couple days worth of food left
here, and after that, I’m gonna need to go out and
search for more. Or I’m gonna need to relocate.
I don’t feel comfortable here anymore, y’know?
Early on, I thought when you got exposed to
the sunlight, it just killed you. But no,
it’s worse. You keep living, you’re
just changed into one of those… Things.
These last few days, I’ve looked out the
windows when I’ve come up at night for food.
I see them sometimes, slithering in the yard or
down the street, these things that used to be
people. I wonder if they’re people
that I knew once, before all this,
then I try to shove that thought out of my mind.
Freaking myself out about all this doesn’t help,
I know that much. I just keep thinking about
how they move, with this weird kind of… purpose?
Like they’re searching for something,
but what could they be searching for?
I’m just gonna go and get more food. We’ll
speak again soon. Stay safe, whoever you are.
Welcome to Day 6. It’s nighttime now, and I’m
heading out for the first time. I keep seeing
these weird, slimy creatures everywhere.
They make me kinda sick to look at them,
but I try my best to just keep moving. I’m
on a mission tonight: I’m gonna go to the
local supermarket and check if there’s still food
there, while also grabbing myself a quick snack.
I’m gonna keep this one brief. I don’t
wanna do a full shopping spree tonight,
it’s already too late. I just
need to know the food is there.
I decided earlier in the night, if I
survive this thing, and the getting is
good at the Bargain Mart, I’ll make my way
back tomorrow for something a little more
substantial. After all, the fewer trips
I make out, the safer I’m likely to be.
By the time I made it to the supermarket, though,
while I was practically a nervous wreck from
the fear of turning into one of those things,
I made an amazing discovery: While the
windows were broken and the floor was a mess,
most of the food was still there.
Day 7. Or should I say, night seven. Galvanized
by my success from the previous days, I decided to
come back to the supermarket with a shopping cart.
I wanted to get enough food for at least a
week, so I wouldn’t need to come back out again.
Hey, maybe I’m not so bad at this
whole apocalypse thing after all…
I grabbed plenty of canned food from the
supermarket. Most of the perishables had
already gone moldy by the time I showed up, so
fresh fruit was out of the question. Suddenly,
I started getting scared about
the thought of scurvy, but
pushed it quickly from my mind. I’d
cross that bridge when I got to it.
Hey hey, it’s Day 8, and I’m still kicking!
That’s gotta count for something, right?
I started taking more trips out at night
time, just to stretch my legs and keep
the blood flowing. When the slithering
things that were once people passed me,
I’d just make myself scarce and hide in the
shadows. I hear them muttering sometimes in their
melted voices. It’s unsettling, but it’s amazing
what you’ll get used to in just over a week.
It’s eerie to see all these streets without
people in them. I know that I should probably
just stay inside, but I can’t. I don’t know if
this will ever just stop, and if it doesn’t,
I don’t want to spend my last
days cooped up in my own basement.
Day 9. You know, there are some benefits
to being in the post-apocalypse, to
ever so slightly offset all the utterly
crushing downsides. While, during the day,
we’re all prisoners of the sun in our own homes,
at night, we can do whatever the hell we want.
I took a baseball bat I keep in my closet
and went to a local furniture store.
I smashed up every single vase and all the
windows, like one of those Rage Rooms, because
nobody could stop me. Then, afterwards,
I went straight to the local computer and
gaming store and took all the AlienWare
tech I could physically carry. There’s
no value in money anymore. If you want
something, you can just go and take it.
Every cloud has a silver lining.
Day 10. More GTA V today. I decided
to get on my headset and speak to the
few others who were still around and
on the servers. It was so nice to speak to
other human beings for once - They came from
all over the world, and they were dealing
with this same “evil sun” insanity as me.
You have no idea how incredibly valuable it is
to find people to talk to in a time like this.
The others players had plenty of theories as
to why all this had happened. Some thought it
was some kind of mutant solar flare they’d
remembered reading about on some conspiracy
forum back in the day. Others speculated that it
was the result of some weapon created by the US or
Russian or Chinese military that’d gone
wrong. One person said that maybe it was
a punishment from God, like maybe,
on some level, we all deserved it.
Things got pretty quiet after that.
Day 11. I’ve been having the most terrible
nightmares lately. It’s probably just the
product of all the stress I’ve been
under lately. But, in the nightmares,
I’m running down a dark street, being chased
by those flesh creatures. I’m moving fast but
they’re moving faster. They’re whispering to me
but I can’t make out anything they’re saying.
This morning - which is to say, this evening
- I woke up screaming and drenched in sweat.
I can’t really explain why, but I feel like
something terrible is going to happen soon…
Okay, okay, I’m alive. That’s enough, isn’t
it? And if you’re watching this, I assume
you’re alive too. Congratulations, Welcome to
the nightmare space between day 11 and day 27.
Sorry that I haven’t been in
contact for so long. As you can see,
I’m not at home anymore. You couldn’t pay me
to go back there - Ha. Not that money is worth
anything anymore. A lot’s happened since I
last made one of these, and I wish I could
tell you any of it was good. Hell, I wish I could
forget it all, but the things I’ve seen and heard…
I don’t think they’re ever gonna
leave my head, no matter what I do.
I thought about making another entry now and
then, but I always found a reason to put it off.
It’s remarkable how all your other priorities
fall away when you’re thinking about where your
next meal is coming from, it just kind of
puts everything in perspective. Of course,
during my travels, I saw more of those
freaks slithering around. Sorry, sorry,
I know I shouldn’t call them that. It’s
kind of a coping mechanism, you know?
It all gets a lot harder when you
have to think of them as… Ex-people.
That’s another thing all those
goofy zombie shows got wrong:
It’s a lot harder to separate what
they were from what they are now,
especially when you know these were
your friends, your neighbors, your…
Well, I can’t avoid talking
about it forever, can I?
I stuffed my backpack with whatever I
could grab and left my home two nights
ago. It wasn’t just because I was going
stir crazy back there, though I admit,
that didn’t exactly help. It was what happened
there. I’d just come back from a food run,
put most of it in the fridge, then retired
back down into the basement to enjoy a
late-night snack and do a little gaming to
keep myself sane. I’d been doing everything
I could to reverse my circadian rhythms
and sleep during the day, just so I could
be fully operational during the twelve-hour
period that going outside wouldn’t melt me.
But just like all those stories
they told us when we were kids:
There are monsters out there at
night, and they’re looking for us.
When I first heard the sound, I wondered if it was
something in-game, or maybe dripping from a leaky
pipe. But no, it was too close to be fake and too
viscous to be water. That’s when I looked at the
door and saw this awful pink slime slithering in
underneath my door. It was one of those things,
those Ex-People, trying to get in. That’d be
bad enough, but then, it started talking to me…
“Kyle… My darling… Why are you all
cooped up down here? It isn’t healthy.
You ought to come out side,
sweetie, get some sun…”
It was my mom. Well, it used to be. Guess
she wanted to come over and visit me.
Needless to say, I got out of there, and I’ve
got no intention of going back. That place is
dead to me now. I don’t ever want to think about
that voice ever again, both her and so… Not her.
So now, I’m on the move, guess I’ll speak to
you again when I stop. Stay safe out there.
Day 28. I decided it was best to make
my way out of town, towards the fringes.
When day first broke, the people who were in the
most densely populated areas were the first to go.
That’s why I decided to hole up in a gas
station last night, just to avoid the sun.
But during the night, people came. Not
Ex-People, actual people. They showed up
in a Jeep outside the building, refueled,
and then came in. They were wearing black,
cobbled-together outfits and hockey masks. They
were all either carrying bats or axes, too.
You can probably understand why I didn’t decide
to introduce myself when they busted their way in.
I concealed myself in a broom
closet while they searched around.
It was nerve-shredding. I’d never been more
thankful in my life than when they left.
Day 29. Coming up on a month of this madness.
After the incident at the gas station,
I realized I needed some kind of defense.
It’s not just the sun and those creatures
I need to worry about. Just like the old
world, people could be dangerous here too.
That’s why I snuck into a gun store in the
dead of night. Some of it had been looted,
but much like the supermarket near my home,
there was plenty still here. The walls were
covered in all manner of rifles, shotguns, and
even submachine guns. I’d heard somewhere that
revolvers are more reliable and easy to maintain
than other types, so since I’m a gun novice,
I grabbed a revolver and stuffed my pockets
with as many bullets as I could carry.
Let’s hope I never need to use any of them.
Day 30. Do I get to call this a month of survival?
If we’re talking February, I’d be a month in
already. What a horribly dubious honor that
is. I saw something disgusting last night and I
thought I’d share it just to get it off my mind.
Last night, as I was moving through the
wilderness, I saw a group of other survivors
gathered around the campfire. I remained scarce
but approached, just to see what was going on,
still carrying my revolver, just to be
safe. But the people around the campfire
were eating something, and when I saw
what they were eating, I almost threw up.
They were chopping up one of the Ex-People,
cooking the parts over the fire, and eating it.
Day 31, a month by anyone’s definition. Ever since
seeing those others eating one of the Ex-people,
I’ve had trouble eating even normal food
myself. My stomach aches and my throat burns.
I feel so weak. I keep laying down and resting.
I know I need to eat soon if I want to survive
to day 32, but every time I think about eating,
I think about the gooey flesh of the Ex-People.
Sometimes, I wish I hadn’t survived this long.
I’ll eat soon. I just need to sleep first…
Day 32 to 43.
If you’ve lived this long,
you really ought to be proud of yourself.
I’ve seen thousands of those slimy Ex-People,
and there are probably millions more
out there - Hell, maybe even billions,
if we’re being honest with ourselves here. Am
I just talking into the void here? Is there
even anyone else out there who’s
human enough to watch this stuff?
Maybe I just need to keep thinking about
posterity. On the off-chance that the world ever
gets better, and we reach some time when children
are born again and all this fades from human
memory, you’ll still have these stupid, pointless
little videos to remember how awful all this was.
That way, at least I can make myself
believe this all had some kind of point.
So, what’s happened? With me, not much. Still
moving at night, surviving, hiding in closets
and underground parking complexes during
daylight. I’m down to my last few cans,
so I’m hoping to hit a supermarket
soon. What a ridiculous way to go:
Starving in this new world, with so
many new, interesting ways to die.
With the Ex-People, things have been a little more
eventful. There used to be one blob to a person,
but they’ve started… Joining up? That’s the best
way I can put it. Things that used to be people
and animals are starting to melt together, getting
bigger and bigger. They’ve never been aggressive,
but I think it’s best to stay out of
their way. Whatever all this is about,
I’m streetwise enough now to
know it can’t be anything good.
I’ll just keep moving, and I hope you can do
the same, whoever the hell you are. Hopefully,
the next time I check in with you,
it’s with better news than this.
Day 44. I saw a shootout on the road
last night. The people who are left,
the ones who are still indeed people, are becoming
less human. Something about situations like this,
this sustained stress and pain and hopelessness,
it weighs on you. There are no rules in the
post-apocalypse, the only thing that can stop
you from doing anything is a bullet to the head.
Five or six people last night, as
afraid and desperate and hungry as me,
gunned each other down. They did this for reasons
I will never understand, even if I wanted to,
because there are no survivors left to tell
the tale. What a funny world we live in.
Day 45. I sleep when I can. It’s surreal, I
remember when I feared the dark and loved bright,
sunny days. Even all this time in, I still don’t
think I’m used to the switch being flipped.
I’ve been having awful dreams
again. I’m still running in them,
with a deep red sun shining up in the sky.
I’m being chased by a mountain of flesh the
size of Mount Everest. It’s swallowing
up the city behind me. It keeps getting
closer. No matter how fast I go, I just
can’t escape. It’ll get me eventually.
Something terrible is going to
happen soon. I just know it.
Day 46. I shot a man today.
I don’t know if he survived;
I hope he lived. We encountered each
other inside an abandoned building.
I think we spooked each other and didn’t have
any time to ask if we were friends or foes.
We were too afraid either way. We both drew
our weapons, and I was faster than he was.
When my revolver discharged and he collapsed,
I ran off. Sun would come up in a few hours,
and I just needed to find another place
to hide. What the hell have I become?
I don’t know how things could
get any worse than this.
Note to self, in the future,
don’t even dare to think
“How could things get any worse?” Because
if I’ve learned anything since this whole
nightmare started, that is never a
rhetorical question. Welcome to the
space between Day 47 and Day 64. If you’re
still alive and watching this, I’m so sorry.
So, I’ve got good news and bad news.
I’ll give you the good news first:
I’ve seen more people who haven’t been changed
yet. And the bad news? Last time I saw them,
they were being dragged out into the light,
kicking and screaming, in the tendrils of one
of those horrible flesh monsters I was telling
you about last time. They’ve gotten a lot
bigger now, and when I told you they weren’t
aggressive, well, I spoke a little too soon.
I can’t just sleep during the day like I used to.
These monsters - and that’s what they are now,
they’re monsters, not people anymore - they
patrol, they hunt. They actively enter buildings,
searching for hiding places, searching for
people they can drag out into the light.
I’ve seen it with my own two eyes - The second
they’re out, they just start melting and fusing
with the mass, making it even bigger, adding
another voice to the chorus. And I hate myself,
cause every time I’ve seen it happen, all
I can think is, “Thank god that’s not me.”
I wish I could do something to help, to save
them, but that’s not the world we live in.
The second they touch the light, it’s already
over. I wouldn’t be helping anyone by adding
my flesh to one of those things. I don’t
want them using my body to get other people.
There’s only one thing I can
do now: Keep moving at night,
stay hidden, get away from population centers.
I’ve realized where I need to go now: I’ve still
got a distant memory of those broadcasts in the
early days of the event. The SCP Foundation. I
noted down coordinates to the nearest facility
they had on the books - And if I’m honest,
“nearest” is only a relative term, cause at this
rate, it’s gonna take me an eternity to get there.
But it’ll be worth it in the end, when I get
there. It’ll all be worth it if I can at least
get some answers, at least know why the world
turned into this Hell. Those SCP folks seemed
better prepared for this than anyone, so even if
they can’t fix this, they’ve at least got to have
answers, right? Somebody needs to have
answers. I really want to believe that.
When the sun goes down, I’ll start
moving again. If you’re watching this,
wish me luck. I don’t have much
food left. I’ll do what I can.
Yeah, I realize I’m not looking great right
now, but trust me, you should see the other guy.
Day 65 to Day 86. Never thought I’d make it
this far, but life’s just full of surprises.
Before you ask - and I mean, why would
you ask? It’s not like I can hear you - it
wasn’t one of the monsters that did this to me,
it was another person, just like me. Desperate,
hungry, afraid. The one difference between
me and them was the fact they had a handgun,
and I didn’t. They asked for all the food I
had, and when I wasn’t exactly forthcoming,
they decided to shoot me, and steal the last
of my food while I lay bleeding on the ground.
Well, that’s not entirely fair. They did leave
me with one protein bar, which I had to cave and
eat a couple of days ago. Since then, I’ve just
been foraging what little food I can from plants
along the way during my nighttime walks. But
it isn’t much, and my wound is giving me grief.
I sure hope they’ve got doctors at this
SCP Foundation, or otherwise, I may be
even more out of luck than I thought.
Here’s the good news for you, since I know
how much you love that. I’m not far off of
the Foundation site now. Even in this state, I’m
probably only a couple of weeks away. I think
maybe I can will myself to live that long,
at least. If I can get some answers just
before I die, then I can die happy. And
sometimes, folks, that’s all you can ask for.
Final stretch. Let’s hope I see you
again on the other end. Stay safe…
But… I don’t understand. Where is everybody?
Hello? Is anybody there? God damn it,
why is nobody here? I don’t understand.
They were meant to have the answers. They
were meant to know what was going on here,
but they’re all gone too. It isn’t fair,
it isn’t fair. Is this it? Is it all just over?
The end of the freaking world as we know it?
It isn’t fair, it isn’t fair, it isn’t fair…
Wait… Are those footsteps? Hello? Yes,
hello, I’m over here! Who’s there?
Oh my god, what the hell is that thing!?
No, no, get away from me, oh god!
“Disgusting…”
Now go check out “When Day Breaks SCP-096”
and “When Day Breaks SCP-049” for more tales
from the nightmarish universe
of SCP-001 - When Day Breaks!